you and J Stone never dropped your
project or my truck Stone did you guys
end up dropping the project together
some new [__] me and stone will put it
together that's only right
that's only how many songs do you guys
have that you're sitting on like hard
drives we got a tape so it's just a
matter of we got to say with stone be
dropping I'll be dropping he drops a lot
for sure you know what I'm saying like
but that's that's family like out of all
of the rappers that you know what I'm
saying like I met or I really crossed
paths with me and stone got a different
type of vibe and of course it came from
from nip but we got our own type of
energy type [__] I love Stone